zone europe / sensations
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro de zone europe / radio
sensations et sur tv sont 18 un numéro
un peu particulier aujourd'hui puisque
nous sommes sur l'île de rhodes en grèce
la grèce un pays d'un peu plus de 10
millions d'habitants elle est membre de
l'union européenne depuis le 1er janvier
1981 elle est membre de la zone euro
depuis le 1er janvier 2001 pendant cinq
jours six délégations venues de toute
l'europe allemagne pays bas france suède
pologne et grèce se retrouve ici à
rhodes pour une série d'ateliers et de
visites autour du pacte vert européen et
des opportunités pour les zones rurales
c'est le projet gira initiatives vertes
dans les zones rurales et nous allons
tenter d'en savoir un petit peu plus au
cours de cette émission
sous drop
[Musique]
nous avons tout de suite rendez-vous à
la chambre de commerce et d'industrie
c'est là-bas que le coup d'envoi du
séminaire est donné avec toutes les
délégations mais quelqu'un vous glisse
bonjour vous êtes le président la maison
de l'europe de rhodes alors est-ce que
déjà pour commencer vous pourriez nous
nous décrire nous présenter cette ville
et cette ville de rhodes macy gray
l'île de rhodes et une île assez ancien
la ville a été fondée en 408 avant
jésus-christ après la réunification des
anciens états de la période grec l'état
de rhode a commencé alors à grandir
jusqu'à devenir un lieu privilégié pour
les sciences et les arts pendant la
période romane et il est unique
vous connaissez sûrement quelques
sculptures locales comme la victoire de
samos reis
le colosse de rhodes la machine
d'anticythère
toutes ces oeuvres ont été créées ici
a-rod
beaucoup d'empereurs romains ont étudié
également ici ils ont appris la langue
d'orienne ainsi que la philosophie et à
part ça l'ancien et a exercé une grande
influence pour la création et le
maintien de la loi maritime ensuite
c'est le temps de l'ordre de malte dont
une grande partie de ses membres étaient
d'origine française notamment la
majorité des grands maîtres c'est pour
cela qu'il existe une importante
tradition chevalière à rhodes
plus tard en 15/100 23 ce produit
l'occupation ottomane la conquête mené
par soliman le magnifique celle ci a
duré jusqu'au début du 20e siècle moment
où les italiens ont soi-disant libérer
l'île mais ils n'ont en fait garder pour
eux mêmes après la deuxième guerre
mondiale finalement l'archipel
dodécanèse présidée par rod retourne à
la grèce voici l'histoire derrière cette
fameuse île touristique cosmopolite et
c'est
donc
aaron dans cette ville qui a été donnée
le lancement le coup d'envoi du projet
gira initiatives vertes dans les zones
rurales quels sont les objectifs de ce
projet
le projet gier a pour objectif de
recueillir les bonnes pratiques en
europe parmi les six pays participant
jiras ce sont les initiales de green
initiative inaugural areas quand nous
évoquons les zones rurales nous
aimerions aussi que les zones insulaires
et les parties les plus isolées soient
comprises dans ce projet les six pays
participant la grèce avec rod la france
l'allemagne la suède la pologne et les
pays-bas organiserons des réunions
localement afin de recueillir des bonnes
pratiques locales et ce en accord avec
le pact au vert pour l'europe et les
objectifs du développement durable
donc de rhodes se situe à l'est au sud
est de la mer egée
quelques dizaines de kilomètres des
côtes turques c'est la plus grande île
du dodécanèse en grèce on y trouve près
de cent vingt mille habitants et ici les
initiatives en faveur de l'environnement
ne manquent pas est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en présenter quelques-unes
des la quatrième plus grande île grecque
comme vous l'avez mentionné il fait
partie de l'archipel dodécanèse dont
plus de 18 ils sont habités avec entrain
habitants et cent vingt mille habitants
comme ici à rhodes notre zone est assez
innovante et pionnière dans l'adaptation
de nouvelles technologies et de
technologies écologiques à petite
échelle chaque île est un petit monde en
soi un petit état par tous doit être
produit de manière locale et cela dépend
des ressources propres nous avons de
bons exemples a-rod liés à l'éco
mobilité et d'autres pratiques que nous
découvrirons plus tard ici mais aussi à
ce type à l'est ou à challes qui tous
ces territoires essaie d'innover de
créer des pratiques qui seront appliqués
ensuite à grande échelle
zone europe
[Musique]
arrêtons-nous maintenant à kamina riz un
petit village situé à une trentaine de
kilomètres au sud de rod sur cette île
80% des habitants dépendent du tourisme
il faut donc à la fois attirer de
nouveaux visiteurs mais aussi protéger
l'environnement ici a été recréé un
ancien village traditionnel grec sorte
de musée à ciel ouvert où l'on peut
venir découvrir les traditions locales
je m'appelle moscou kulas je suis l'un
des responsables de ce village
traditionnel
l'idée derrière ce lieu est de créer une
réplique d'un ancien village comme ceux
qui existaient dans cette zone a-rod
celui ci présente la culture
traditionnelle l'éthique et l'histoire
de nos villages
cela comprend notre gastronomie locale
les traditions et les métiers qui
existait ici par le passé
tout cela combiné bien sûr avec la
nature et l'histoire de cette zone qui
est très très anciennes
pour l'environnement nous valorisons les
plantes la faune et la flore locales de
la région
par exemple l'origan le teint les
orchidées pousse ici à rhodes
le tourisme et l'environnement sont
selon moi bien interconnectés à mon avis
rod soutiendra et inclura les questions
environnementales en ce qui concerne le
tourisme
bien évidemment les plages et le soleil
seront toujours présents ici mais nous
avons également des paysages
exceptionnels à visiter forêts rivières
et des barrages dans cette partie de
l'île à
son europe
[Musique]
découvrons une nouvelle initiative ici
sur l'île de rhodes dans le parc juste à
côté des sources qualité à les hôtels
mais aussi les écoles sont mis à
contribution pour nettoyer les lieux
je m'appelle l'icta russe kalaï rue et
je suis le responsable de la société à
un pacte social il ya taf ici en
français nature commune
nous avons actuellement dans un parc un
parc que nous souhaitons transformer en
lieu de sensibilisation à
l'environnement
pour nous il est très important de
fournir un espace aux étudiants où ils
peuvent comprendre la nature
what comment créer de la vue à partir de
zéro
jusqu'à obtenir une vie que tu peux
toucher sentir écouté respirer
car tout dans la nature respire a ouvert
les portes des quarts
donc c'est pour cela qu'il est essentiel
d'expliquer aux jeunes aux filles les
garçons
les connexions
la connexion qui existait entre eux
mêmes et la nature donc si nous agissons
en tant que société à un pacte social
dans un projet en collaboration avec les
propriétaires des hôtels
nous invitons les personnes logeant dans
ses hôtels what else à venir travailler
ici de manière bénévole
pour nettoyer et préserver le parc afin
de le rendre étudiants
les étudiants viennent ensuite apprendre
la nature
locale donc de cette manière nous
combinons tourisme et populations
locales industrie du tourisme et
environnement
des six bateaux et à twin spark
à la fin ce projet s'étalera sur un parc
de 100 mille mètres carrés
square meters
extrêmement bien conservé
non seulement pour la population locale
mais également pour tous les européens
qui veulent venir et apprendre sur la
nature chez nous
en europe
[Musique]
les sources de qualité à son réputé
depuis l'antiquité elles ont ensuite été
reconstruite en 1929 lors de
l'occupation italienne puis restauré en
1999 elle constitue un très bel exemple
d'intégration de l'architecturé en plein
milieu naturel je suis michael k vous
clis président de la maison de l'europe
à rhodes et hôte de la réunion de
l'initiative grecque et green initiative
in rural areas un projet financé par
erasmus et par la commission européenne
nous sommes au bain de qualité à une
attraction culturelle est une des
principales enclave de rhodes c'est une
zone de spa dans laquelle les visiteurs
boivent de l'eau spécial que nous
retrouvons uniquement ici pour traiter
des maladies du rein ou autres bacs une
pratique notamment popularisé lors de
l'occupation italienne faire 1829
ces bains ont été restaurés en 2009 et
ouvert ensuite au public depuis c'est
l'une des attractions les plus
populaires est mieux préservé drogue cet
endroit offre de beaux paysages naturels
à côté de la mer et avec plein de
rochers un espace culturel insolite
utilisé comme lieu de célébration des
cérémonies pour des mariages ou de
grands événements pour la population
locale mais aussi un grand jardin
botanique avec des plantes et des épices
typiques de l'île de rhodes
propose
nous proposons ce projet ici car c'est
un bel exemple de coopération entre
citoyens et municipalités en grèce qui
allie héritage culturel et développement
durable c'est une manière de
sensibiliser sur la question de
l'environnement en utilisant des
paysages connus à l'international
europe
[Musique]
je me trouve actuellement dans la vallée
des papillons à une dizaine de
kilomètres de l'aéroport de rhodes ici
au mois de juin on peut trouver des
espèces très rares de papillons présent
dans très peu d'endroits sur terre cela
fait de cette vallée un lieu
incontournable de la biodiversité de
l'île de rhodes
tous je m'appelle anarchie j'ai été
l'une des présidente fondatrice de la
maison de l'europe de rhodes oui
nous sommes ici dans la vallée des
papillons situé dans la partie noah de
rhodes
ouais il s'agit d'une vallée où chaque
été en juin mais des millions de
papillons viennent de beaucoup
d'endroits pour y vivre est passé
l'époque estivale entre juin et
septembre
c'est à dire pendant la période adultes
de l'homme
ces papillons dont la durée de vie est
de seulement un an
change et se métamorphosent 4e fois
metamorphosis portant de flybe
l'étape adultes se déroulent pendant
l'été est la période des examens se
produit à la fin de l'essai comme c'est
le cas en ce moment fin septembre
il devait
d'abord
stadium
pendant l'hiver et ce jusqu'au mois de
mars nous sommes dans la période de
métamorphose de la chenille
centers durant cette période le papillon
habitent dans les panthers et j'ai
ensuite il s'introduit dans le sol sous
les am inn dé coco pour y passer la
période de courson
dans son cocon il se transforme en
insectes volants non le papillon que
nous connaissons
par rapport à d'autres endroits ce qui
est particulière ici c'est la
concentration très élevée de papillons
wc millien de papillon ça n'existe qu'à
rhodes ils viennent habib pas et passent
l'été dans cet espace ce phénomène a été
étudié par beaucoup d'auto mollo j0
décosse et le joue un rôle fondamental
dans cette profonde vallée elle est
suffisamment sombre va les big three
shadows les grands arbres pour avoir de
l'ombre des températures basses en été
ce sont d'autres conditions favorables
pour les papilles
bécaud souika biomed et eto'o nous
sommes dans le meilleur environnement
pour qu'ils vivent leur père d'abus
sont europe
[Musique]
on va faire une pause gourmande à
présent dans une europe vous le savez on
aime vous faire voyager dans l'assiette
est ici en grèce on mange du tzatziki de
la feta mais nous on va vous faire
découvrir une autre cette traditionnelle
dans les cuisines du restaurant tamar
yassa
bonjour je suis nikos iris je suis le
propriétaire du restaurant tam arias à
ce beau lieu au milieu de la ville de
rhodes et aujourd'hui nous allons
préparer une recette locale appelée kita
ou dit
c'est un plat que vous pourrez trouver
dans toutes les villes de rhodes
c'est une recette simple et végétarienne
mais très savoureuse surface remettait
d'abord nous devons couper les
courgettes et les émincer jusqu'à
obtenir des fines tranches ensuite on
laisse reposer
après nous prenons des pois chiches
parfois très coloré passe des poivrons
de trois couleurs et
d'autre
du cumin et met du sel et du coin ont
lésé m'associe pour former une espèce de
pâte et ont laissé goûter
[Musique]
à la fin on mélange l'ensemble avec des
aides jusqu'à femme et une belle nas et
on la place dans une poêle avec un peu
d'huile de tournesol pour la frire un
peu d'huile de tournesol a pas beaucoup
c'est très important pour notre recette
il faut mettre le feu à haute
température pour obtenir une texture
croquante à l'extérieur et moelleux à
l'intérieur et voilà on saupoudre un pot
de fromage feta par dessus et puis ces
prêts pour la dégustation
le python ruby c'est l'un des plats les
plus typiques que vous pouvez trouver à
rhodes
en europe
je retrouve à présent mari raphaël
milliers de la maison de l'europe des
yvelines est responsable de centre
europe direct de saint germain en laye
je voudrais que vous faisiez un petit
peu plus sur ce projet gira il s'inscrit
dans la continuité du projet riz dit
s'il était consacrée à vent à la
citoyenneté active en milieu rural tout
à fait et une fois ce projet chloé
approuvé par l'agencé a smooth on nous a
dit mais pourquoi ne pas aller plus loin
vous avez parlé de la citoyenneté active
à présent on a c'est qu'ils formidable
qui est le nouveau pacte vert européen
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait pour dynamiser
les autres vont mal donc on a réécrit un
nouveau projet pour 30 mois et quels
sont les objectifs de ce projet
de pouvoir rendre public un maximum de
personnes une boîte à outils des
initiatives qu'on aura vu au cours de
ces trente mois dans les différents pays
visités c'est à dire que quelqu'un issu
d'une zone rurale en grèce en suède en
france ou en pologne puisse se dire ça
c'est chouette on va essayer de le
reproduire et les financements européens
ah oui on peut les obtenir comme ça on a
vu qu'il y avait beaucoup de délégations
six au total ce sont des partenaires de
ce projet alors on à la maison de
l'europe de bad marienberg en allemagne
qui est le coordinateur du projet la
maison de l'europe des yvelines en
france la fondation robert schuman en
pologne la maison de l'europe de javier
borg en suède et la maison de l'europe
de rhodes qu'est ce que vous retenez de
ce meeting jusqu'à présent à rodez qu'il
ya des initiatives qui pourraient être
pourquoi pas reprise dans notre région
en france oui tout à fait alors ce que
je retiens c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
bonne volonté
même dans des îles par exemple ici à
rhodes ou jusqu'à présent on avait des
problèmes de pollution de traitement des
déchets etc on voit que les gens même
des générations d'avant ou envie de
changer les choses et je pense notamment
aux plastiques à la présentation qu'on a
eu
groupe ige en plastique ce qui récupère
les vieux masquer les bouts de plastique
et qui fait du mobilier urbain
de la déco d'intérieur je me dis ça je
pense qu'on a le savoir-faire pour le
faire et malheureusement suffisamment de
déchets en france pour avoir la matière
première
sous drop
[Musique]
escale à présent sur l'île de challes
qui situé à 6 km à l'ouest de rhodes
lille vient de lancer un nouveau plan de
transition énergétique
je m'appelle basilio ce ressac hills et
je suis le maire adjoint chargé des
questions de croissance économique et
tourisme ici sur l'île de challes qui
nous avons présenté en octobre 2010
notre plan de transition énergétique au
secrétariat européen pour le climat et
l'énergie
et depuis nous essayons d'atteindre nos
objectifs est de respecter notre vision
celle ci est très simple décarbonés
ville de celle qui
nous avons mis en place les éléments
nécessaires pour le faire
parmi eux il y à la construction d'un
parc photovoltaïque de 1 mégawatt afin
de couvrir les besoins énergétiques de
lille comme les logements les
entreprises
et meynac ce taux d'ici deux ans nous
espérons que la situation se soit
améliorée et que nous aurons réduit nos
émissions de co2 de 40 à 50%
c'est très important car il s'agit de
l'avenir nous allons sauver la planète
et nous avons notre rôle à jouer
land of talk et pas seulement sur l'île
de celle qui j'espère que tous ceux qui
nous écoutent se rendent compte qu'il
faut sauver la planète pour les
générations à venir
l'organisation est la clé pour
nous devons tous faire de notre mieux
pour réduire nos émissions de co2 et
faire de notre planète un endroit plus
agréable et sur à vivre
son europe
[Musique]
sommes au coeur du parc marin plutôt
qu'à une zone protégée qui bénéficie de
conditions environnementales
exceptionnelle et c'est ici qu'une ferme
à poissons a été installé
je m'appelle sa basque et nicolas ou et
je suis biologiste marin nous sommes
dans une ferme d'aquaculture que vous
voyez derrière moi et qui s'appelle la
mare à
la mare est une entreprise familiale
productrice de poissons de nerfs de
quatre espèces 71 var dorade rose et
coop commun
toutes ces espèces dont la production
s'élève à environ 320 tonnes par an
sont élevées localement l'objectif de
l'entreprise est que le produit soit
aussi consommer de manière locale le
marché de rhodes et riche de ces
poissons pendant toute l'année
pourquoi avons nous choisi ces poissons
gries
car la grèce est depuis déjà plusieurs
années un endroit idéal pour produire
des protéines de poissons d'une grande
qualité et ce grâce à l'excellent
environnement que nous avons dans les
mers de la grèce notamment la mer egée
en plus la qualité des poissons est
renforcée par la présence des acides
gras oméga-3 de qualité très bénéfique
pour les êtres humains
cette zone est spécialement intéressante
car elle se situe dans la partie ouest
de rhodes or comme vous le savez rod est
une île très touristique
et bien dans cette zone nous n'avons
aucune activité touristique agriculture
al industriels ou domestiques qui
pourrait avoir un impact sur la qualité
des eaux
grâce aux principales caractéristiques
océanographique de la région et les
magnifiques paysages 10 île rocheuse
les eaux sont profondes et les courants
sont forts c'est
la qualité de l'eau est exceptionnel et
les poissons sont très heureux ici
[Musique]
nous avons mené une révolution au sein
de cette activité parce que
nous avons réussi dans une île
touristique comme celle ci à combiner
tourisme et aquaculture
[Musique]
se sent fier de pouvoir dire que notre
travail amène des visiteurs à découvrir
la ferme d'aquaculture
comprendre le processus d'élevage et de
production
ainsi que leur montrer le niveau de
respect de cet environnement aquatique
comme vous le voyez derrière vous les
visiteurs peuvent tissi nager et
constater tout cela par eux mêmes plutôt
que de manière théorique
nous les laissons faire du snorkeling
autour de la zone pour qu'ils puissent
voir la clarté des eaux et les
conditions dans lesquelles grandi ces
poissons
cette zone et protéger les règles de la
ferme ainsi que celle du gouvernement
interdise la pêche
grâce à cette protection un refuge s'est
créé pour beaucoup de poissons et de
dauphins les dauphins adore poursuivre
les poissons sans oublier des très
grands ton
en résumé ces initiatives pour
l'environnement marin sont ceux que les
plongeurs m découvrir
et c'est pourquoi on essaye de combiner
la pratique de la plongée dans les zones
proches des cages
possible de rencontrer des grands oncles
et même des offenses
ici vous avez 50 % de chances de
rencontrer des dauphins est bien
évidemment une probabilité de 100% de
voir des tons les plongeurs sont ravis
de vivre cette expérience unique au
milieu de la vie marine de saison
zone europe
[Musique]
zone europe s'est terminée une émission
spéciale enregistrée à rhodes en grèce
très bonne soirée à tous moi je retourne
nager
[Musique]
zone europe / sensation
zone europe avec le soutien financier de
la région ile de france